boa tarde
primeiro queria agradecer aos jovens
jogadores o evento para conversar um
pouco com vocês sobre a infância soluçou
dentro do núcleo do poder no brinquedo
poder da roupa havia 2 traz a criança
alguém se riu e se os ponteiros iniciar
levando de nossos fãs todos os mesmos
francesa o mais alegre uma crise com
fatos mais marcantes - marcantes mas de
fato que nós passamos por essa fase deve
sumir livro passei pela mídia dando bola
caçando passarinhos nos moldando anos
aquela coisa daquele tempo mais antigo
que era tudo entrou na loja
hoje é tudo digital onde as crianças é o
videogame já em tarde veio até para
pegar passageiro netão fica aquela coisa
muito mecânica mas ainda com alguma
criança dentro de uma quadra de escola
ou o botão de volta no caminho ela se
alegra com aquilo na minha infância por
uma infância marcada por momentos de
dificuldade de lado pela falta do
recurso financeiro para aquela
dificuldade toda de criança criado sem
pai pai perdia os três anos de idade
então essa coisa foi é molinho e eu tive
que trabalhar no concelho e comecei a
trabalhar eu gostava muito de matemática
e física e aí fui estudando em nova
rejeito trabalho de professor particular
a gente dava aula de matemática difícil
e depois foi contratado por um colégio
de nossa sociedade
o corpo de nossa cidade o colégio das
irmãs no ano de 1978
lá eu tive a oportunidade
no final do ano de ser convidado com o
colaborador para fazer uma distribuição
de brinquedos para crianças carentes na
zona rural de teresina isso no ano de
1978 e eu fui aquela distribuição
ao terminar aquilo dali mim fiquei
encantado me lembrei do meu tempo de
criança e vi aquela turma era mais ou
menos são mais 150 crianças naquela
história toda é muito alegre muita
felicidade e pensei logo comigo negócio
bonito vamos vamos ver o que a gente faz
para continuar no ano seguinte já em
agosto setembro
comecei a procurar aquelas pessoas que
haviam convidados sim como é que estão
os preparativos para o natal aquela
coisa toda e eu fui vendo as pessoas
esfriando um pouco e eu tomei a frente
comecei a dar aula particular juntar um
dinheirinho e fui chamando e outro de
tal forma que montamos brinquedos no âm
no andaime e fomos levar novamente
quando terminou foi novamente aquela
volta ao passado aquela alegria de
crianças daquela coisa toda e com isto o
tempo foi passando e vocês já conseguem
e aí já mais ou menos no ano de 1984
quando a gente já conseguia colocar num
em uma kombi mas já conseguia colocar em
um caminhão já conseguia colocar em um
caminhão mais um caminhãozinho aberto lá
no fundo é e aí as pessoas formavam as
filas tudo na zona rural porque zona
rural porque é uma população mais pobre
mais carente marcos assistida e aí a
gente foi conseguindo fazer isso aí
isso aqui as pessoas recebiam os
brinquedos e saíam para suas comunidades
já levando os saquinhos aquela alegria
toda veio ano já em 1995 eu sempre
trabalhei para tentar levar para essas
crianças uma maior quantidade de
brinquedos e com melhor qualidade e isso
aí é uma noite de natal 24 de dezembro
para 15
a omd aqui na zona rural de teresina a
gente começa a distribuir as senhas às
18 horas
as pessoas recebem assim a gente leva a
um pacto em diversa eles brincam e
depois também faço à noite a e dormindo
então ele não esperando no dia seguinte
entram os caminhões aqui já agora em
2011 onde a gente já estava atingindo
atendendo mais de 20 mil pessoas
isso aqui é o campo onde a gente faz a
primeira concentração onde a gente
distribui as pessoas já vão levando os
seus fatos
isso aqui em uma outra comunidade na
comunidade de santa teresa vocês parecem
ser um verdadeiro do mundo que nada vai
dar certo para essa maus honra do mundo
mas todo mundo aqui está com sua senha
no gozo e os caminhões estão chegando
para todos receberem o seu kit de
brinquedo o que eu não admito que eu
digo para os meus colaboradores é que
ninguém saia sem seu kit pode levar dois
porque eu também com criança eu não ia
passar uma noite na fila para receber um
saco eu ia fazer tudo receber dois então
23 você pode você não pode sair daqui
sem nada
então isso aí acontece aí é uma imagem a
fim daquela que a gente tem que levar
agradecer ao papai do céu no dia 25 de
dezembro às 14 horas 13 horas quando o
sol pa enfim uma coisa tá acabando ea
gente lembra e olha o passado meu deus
do céu deu certo todo mundo conseguimos
atingir a todos graças a deus
esta foto observe bem é uma foto é um
novo a foto bonita foco de princesas
a foto de adolescente de mocinhas isso
aqui é uma foto do dia 24 de dezembro à
noite elas estavam um campo esperando
para receber as suas senhas
vejam que estão todas fazendo o pouso
mas se vocês observarem as roupinhas
delas são muito sofridas dizer quando
você vai nós vamos para uma festa
principalmente uma festa de natal das
maiores festas do ano a festa do
renascimento certo do nascimento de
cristo festa da luz festa da esperança
festa da alegria a gente procura botar o
que a gente tem de melhor sorte melhor
para essa comunidade é isso aí
a idéia é imagem bonita esta daí observa
a decorrer
eu pensei também eu vou distribuir
também tem como fazer isso meu deus do
céu
vamos pra frente pensei assim eu tenho
que além dos brinquedos os brinquedos
eles a gente chega na sua na comunidade
as pessoas não se aproxima muito da
gente elas vêm e recebem aquela sacola e
vou embora já não têm muita oportunidade
de conversar e eu pensei comigo então
agora eu vou começar a distribuir roupa
roupa ela é ela dá mais dignidade
já pensou os 68 estão cada pessoa são as
moças mais bonitas do que a outros rapaz
cada um mais bonito nos jogos bonitos
andando mais bem vestido do que os
outros
vocês estão vendo tudo isto ano com
essas roupas aqui que eu estou vestindo
são roupas na guitarra
são roupas que a gente entrega são
roupas que a gente distribui às vezes e
vocês tenham certeza disso e eu vou lhes
dizer porque eu estou todos os dias
agora desde o túmulo visitando as
comunidades
as pessoas não têm internacional levando
um novo pra vestir no dia de natal
na realidade as roupas novas e elas têm
são as roupas que recebe como é feito
isso eu vou às comunidades
isso aqui é lá na comunidade ypiranga
vai de futebol
você falava no intercâmbio isso aquela
intimou no povoado piranhas eu rogo
odessa periferia de teresina ea vitimou
procurando as pessoas mais pobres mais
necessitadas e aonde você encontra mais
falta de dinheiro falta de escolaridade
falta tudo não falta
não falta a felicidade eu cheguei mas
acaba com a senhora e os de filhos 11
uma latinha de sardinha mesmo dia um
pouco de arroz já há aquele negócio
quando eu cheguei na hora do almoço
tanto o conselho tem o seu valor está
com a gente quando eu olhei que veio
aqui olho mais de um sorriso daqui pra
lá 11 filhos
a rússia vai trazer nossa fichinha então
pessoal
nós temos que nos acertarmos a nossa
inteligência nós estamos aqui somos
formadores de opinião do nosso mundo
aqui é muito nos óleos à pobreza
ela existe ela vem acompanhado de
sofrimento mas ela vem acompanhada
também de muitas
muitas pessoas felizes e ovos vamos nos
aproximar delas
nós temos o preconceito um pó branco o
ladrão ou vivenciado o cobre também é
gente
efe
sentado em outra comunidade pedreiras
timon região que conhece a pessoa tem um
palco
nós começamos a história das roupas e
traz dignidade que trazem alegria como
fazer isso meu deus do céu só tem que
ser da casa
graças a deus eu sou muito bem casado
com minha mulher gosta do que faz e
gosta de fazer e nós abrimos mão do
conforto das coisas de nossa casa onde
passa o ano todo
no entanto fazendo o papel das coisas
isso aqui foi já em 2005 a 10 atrás mas
começam a comprar peças de roupa e um
boné uma região muito muito que todo
mundo dizia que era muito violenta na
favela mas na favela o que foi a única
favela invadida infectada pela polícia
eu nunca tive problema porque eles
precisavam de alguma coisa
uma série de juízes a gente estava com o
fofo atenção é o que nós temos que ser
hoje somos pessoas com lanças
bem aventurados os mansos o que é ser
mantido é ser prestativo sejamos
quiserem com ovos bem aventurados os
misericordiosos vamos partilhar
vamos pensar no próximo
com isso nós estamos fazendo uma
sociedade mais justa e humana com
pessoas mais começou essa história
hoje todos vivos
alguns menores trabalhando
falta tudo junto com a roupinha nova
em educação e saúde há pessoas precisam
eu até concordo que isso aí faz
necessário mas tem que pensar na criança
hoje a criança recebendo aquele
brinquedo nessa língua aquela roupinha
nova ela corre vai dizer que recebeu é
aquela alegria que ela leva a um chefe
na vila hoje 2015
quem quiser a convidava a entrega de 300
clientes amanhã recebe só de calçado do
zagueiro na calça e cueca boxer linda
não vou mostrar a camisa tudo muito
bonito aqui a entrega para as crianças
ele recebe até um setor do calçado
brinquedos é tudo dividido para essas
coisas
embora uma muda de roupa ele recebe uns
a ópera tem uma família unida
se não tiver uma família de fé em deus
aí a minha família mais velho lucas joão
gabriel que a filha água aqui são os
meus colaboradores são mais de 200
pessoas pobres e humildes muito deles
recebe um salário mínimo mas se dispõe a
passar o mês
em dezembro trabalhando lá com
documentação para organizar a festa do
natal a mas a bonequinha vai se quebrar
a o carro vai se separar a água vai
rasgar pai e alegria que a pessoa teve
que subir e sair ela leva com a vitamina
exemplo seu todo dia
vários desses voluntários por crianças
que receberam aí ele chega de marcelo
hoje eu queria saber como é que eu faço
pra poder me ajuda eu quero ser seu
faltaria então isso foi a semente
plantada
se cada um plantar uma semente neste
nível
nós vamos ter uma sociedade mais justa
aqui é uma forma de lembrar de um amigo
meu ele tinha passado em teresina
por ter sido um grande jogador convivi
com ele muitos fizeram muitas travessias
todos os prédios que eu cheguei a
construir passava noites e dois
conversamos e ele me dizia uma coisa que
dizer também para os alunos
isso aqui é o melhor que eu não quero
ser melhor que eu não sou gay mas aqui é
o meu melhor e eu posso fazer para fez
para aquelas pessoas que precisam do meu
trabalho na minha ligação do meio com
amor ao próximo
nós temos que pensar no amor a caridade
não é tamanho que o amor é que eu faço
um desafio ajudar
tchau é conversando é ouvido e se
aproximando é fazendo bem e querendo
odeia
eu vou fazer o bem não é só fazer é ter
direito nei
então se a gente faz isso mas vamos ter
dias felizes
faço essa experiência as palmas e no
final vocês vão dirigir a mim eu peço
que não seja o caminho mais seguro para
a dona luzia aquela mãe de nove filhos
que eu fiz questão de trazer comigo
levante a segunda visita
meu muito obrigado e aceita um detalhe